[Music]
as we count down to super bowl 55 we're
looking at how health officials are
working with the nfl
to make sure the big game does not turn
into a super spreader event
raymond james stadium which holds 65 000
people
will be at roughly one-third capacity as
the buccaneers face off
against the chiefs sunday jamie yukas
got rare pregame access
inside the stadium to show us what's
being done to keep the super bowl
covid free jamie good morning
good morning anthony welcome to raymond
james stadium it is an open air stadium
and that's a good thing
i also want to show you these giant led
light panels they're not just going to
be used for entertainment value
they're also going to be used to keep
fans in the sands separate
from the players on the field the other
thing that nfl is going to do
hand out these n95 mask
n95 mask to all fans who show up here on
sunday
and every chance that the workers get
they're going to tell the fans to keep
those masks on
hand sanitizer face coverings require
six feet
separating here as you wait in line
covid is making peter o'reilly's job
more complicated this year the top here
you see those reminders
o'reilly who oversees stadium activity
for all 32 teams
partnered with state and local health
officials along with the cdc
to keep sunday's super bowl spectators
healthy
all 22 thousand of them is there any
concern
that this could become a super spreader
event that people leave here and they go
home and they have coven
we feel very confident in our protocols
and we've got
the learnings from more than 115 games
this season
there's been no cluster spread coming
out of any of those games
in addition to mandatory mass fans will
be properly distanced in the stands
with three open seats between each pod
and
everything from ticketing to concession
stand purchases
will be done electronically what happens
when people do have one too many beers
and maybe get a little lackadaisical and
and making sure that they're standing
where they're supposed to or having
their mask on
we have a significant number of staff
whose role it is is to remind people
we've got tremendous amount of signage
tremendous amount of sanitizer our rules
say you have to be able to
look in front of you and behind you and
be able to see a hand sanitizing station
so they're that prominent
florida has been hit hard by covet with
more than 1.7 million coronavirus cases
since the start of the pandemic
florida is open florida governor ron
desantis has come under fire
for criticizing mass mandates and
casting doubt on lockdowns
can the city handle this we can handle
it we are in a downward
trajectory in our positive cases
but we are not taking our eye off of the
ball tampa mayor jane castor
issued an executive order requiring
people to mask up
in densely populated outdoor areas
the penalty for those who don't a 500
dollar fine
i got to ask you i've walked around here
a little bit there are a lot of people
not wearing masks
how are you going to enforce it
especially outside most people aren't
used to wearing them
outdoors but our community
will adhere and then we expect that the
visitors will as well
people arrive at the airport the first
thing they're going to hear is you need
your sunscreen your sunglasses and your
mask
is there a lot of pressure on you to get
this right there is i understand the
responsibility and i accept it
the players coaches and their entire
households are all being tested for
covet
every day leading up to super bowl
sunday the tampa mayor says she expects
the only people to leave tampa
disappointed
are the kansas city fans we'll have to
wait to see about that and in case you
were wondering
yes anthony you are doing your part
to make sure that the fans are spread
out you guys got good seats too you're
in section 115.
okay we were wondering about that that's
the closest we've been together since
the virus
as well jamie jamie you said those are
good seats because klaus who's there on
steadicam
sent me that picture yesterday i said
rst it's good he goes they're in the
corner of the end zone near the cbs set
not great
they look good they look good in that
picture i think jamie's being nice
it's better for the better for the lives
if you can get us an upgrade jamie see
if you can work on it
listen we're just thrilled to be there
we're thrilled to be there
nice job jamie thank you jamie thank you
very much